bonjour pierre laurin merci de répondre
à nos questions quels sont les enjeux de
ce nouveau scrutin exactement bonjour
les enjeux viennent d'être défini d'une
manière etc tu es très très bien
il s'agit maintenant d'entrer dans une
nouvelle phase de la vie politique russe
jusqu'à présent les choses se dérouler
selon un principe qui étaient
directement inspirée de la cinquième
république française c'est à dire un
président qui décide de tout avec un
gouvernement qui exécute une parlement
qui enregistre et
une participation
de la population relativement limitée en
dehors des des élections maintenant on
passe dans un système que l'on peut
qualifier de semis par le menton c'est à
dire que
le parlement la chambre basse en tout
cas la douma va choisir le premier
ministre en fonction des rapports de
force à l'intérieur du
du parlement il est très clair que là
étant donné que le parti présidentiel
russie unie va remporter
vraisemblablement les élections d'une
manière relativement large moins large
que la dernière fois mais
confortable que le parti présidentiel
aura la majorité absolue mais peut-être
pas la majorité
qualifiée pour changer la constitution
ce qu'elle avait jusqu'à présent donc le
premier ministre viendra de cette
formation mais il sera chargé de gérer
lui même enfin avec le gouvernement le
dossier les dossiers économiques et
sociaux du pays le président lui
supervisant ayant disant de ce point de
vue là un rôle plus en retrait il ne se
mêlera pas de ces questions sauf pour
inciter à aller dans un sens ou dans un
autre en revanche il conservera les
portefeuille régalien
les affaires étrangères
la défense la sécurité et ce sera lui
qui
s'occupera de ces dossiers donc il ya
une sorte de partage des tâches qui
n'est pas exactement celle qui avait
lieu jusqu'à aujourd'hui où qu'ils se
manifestent les pays dans les régimes
présidentiels comme justement la france
pierre laurin vous avez évoqué un le
camp présidentiel certains sondages
prévoient des scores en baisse pour
russie unie même si le pouvoir le parti
au pouvoir conserverait une majorité au
parlement en quoi est-ce que ça peut
modifier le rapport de force entre
l'opposition et le pouvoir compte de la
popularité de vladimir poutine en russie
la popularité de vladimir poutine qui
était très élevé au moment de l' affaire
de crime et le rattachement de la crimée
puisqu'il atteignait 80%
maintenant on est à peu près 60 contre
60 et 65% donc cette popularité lui
permet effectivement de continuer à
peser d'une manière considérable sur la
vie politique
il permet également enfin cette
popularité permet également à russie
unie
d'obtenir un résultat qui sera
certainement très honorable mais
effectivement on n'a pas la dynamique de
du rattachement de la crimée et en plus
ces dernières années ont été marquées
par
différents problèmes
intérieurs en particulier une réforme
des retraites qui est très mal passée
qui était indispensable mais qui est
très mal passer auprès de l'opinion et
qui d'ailleurs a coûté complètement sa
popularité au premier ministre medvedyev
dimitri medvedev a complètement disparu
des élections il ne se présente pas dans
la liste fédérale parce que c'est
aujourd'hui medvedyev est un boulet
alors que c'était quelqu'un qui était
présenté comme quelqu'un de très
dynamique et de positif jusqu'à présent
maintenant ce sont des valeurs sûres le
russie unie qui dirige la liste c'est à
dire le ministre de la défense choïgou
qui avait d'âgés déjà
participé comme tête de liste aux
élections il y a quelques années et le
ministre de l'intérieur lavrov et ces
deux personnalités représentent en gros
d'un coup le désert saharien la marche
des affaires étrangères exactement et
ces deux personnalités représente d'un
côté la force et de l'autre côté
l'agilité diplomatique de la russie
parce que lavrov est l'une des
personnalités russes qui est le mieux
reconnues sur le plan international et
qui se découpent et bien justement sur
le plan international un mot aussi sur
l'ingérence on l'a vu avec le duplex
d'anthony claireaux à notre
correspondant à moscou les autorités
russes se disent vigilante qu'en est il
réellement
elles se disent vigilants parce que il
est très clair que les on a beaucoup
parlé des ingérences sur russe dans les
élections américaines ou dans les
élections d'autres pays mais c'est
vraiment dérisoire par rapport aux
ingérences des pays occidentaux dans les
élections en russie ou dans d'autres
pays d'ailleurs c'est à dire que healy a
d'une part un financement des partis de
certains partis politiques qui m'a pas
et complètement interdits et les partis
qui sont qui reçoivent ou les groupes
qui reçoit des financements de
l'étranger sont qualifiés d'agents
étrangers comme cela se pratique
d'ailleurs aux états unis donc ils ne
peuvent pas participer aux élections ce
qui empêcherait
normalement
le l'organisation de manifestations dans
le genre
comme celles qui se sont passées en
ukraine la révolution orange ou en
serbie ou plus tard en géorgie ou en
biélorussie
il n'y aura pas de possibilité de
permettre à des organisations piloté par
l'étranger de créer des problèmes en
russie en revanche et c'est très
important pour les autorités russes ces
élections doivent être irréprochables
une fois que les partis éventuelle de
l'étranger ont été éliminés il faut que
la loi électorale soit respectée et
qu'il n'y ait pas de
d'accusations de fraudes en tout cas de
fraude massive parce que la fraude hélas
dans un pays comme la russie tellement
étendues et où les autorités locales par
par moments tiennent à se faire bien
voir du pouvoir la fraude est
pratiquement inévitable mais il faut
qu'elle reste dans une limite comme ça
s'était passé en 2016 les élections de
2016 avait été très honnête et il n'y
avait pas eu de contestations véritable
à part quelques quelques broutilles
comme celle que je viens de dire
merci pierre laurin d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste
écrivain spécialiste de la russie et de
l'ex urss